what makes a good superhero teamwork I
think you know sacrifice putting others
for yourself all those things that we
were told to do that our parents don'ts
to do we're young you know what was your
most surprising moment in your time of
filming when I died you know we didn't
we never read the script like we are
given our individual bedtime in the
movies I at the premiere I was like what
when you get cast in a superhero movie
you're thinking CGI are you thinking
superpowers you're not necessarily
thinking really motion but throughout
the course of your time at MCU you have
some incredibly emotional moments and
personal laws did you know that going
into it yeah I mean she is notorious for
having really bad things happen to her
she's the ultimate survivor and she
shuts that's the only thing I can think
of her just like she has all her powers
I think comes from her huge amount of
empathy as well and her ability to feel
and care and love but so to all these
characters but it's um it's funny being
always the fat girl TVs causing trouble
over on the other podium purple tonight
Louise I like II kind of thing but this
is a tearful say pebble has been watched
too much you didn't get into the
infinity war is and neither did Jeremy
Renner aka Hawkeye you guys just
spending dad time doing dad tips yeah a
lot of a lot of barbecues
a lot of just tossing the ball yeah
and quality time with the kids got one
of those things it's like three bars and
you throw the weighted rope and it spins
around you hope to catch it no it's not
it's not a yo-yo
it's a lawn game it's kind of like it's
like a poor man's cornhole that's the
that's a second time I've said that once
again
you came correct the shoe game remains
strong do you feel pressure to do that I
[Music]
love when you say water my favorite part
of the movie when I was a scientist
shoulders you know it was like just
reliving all the English and what you
know wrecked all the the morning stuff
you know and it was a very physical to
so yeah but that was fun too
I assume you did not sit on Josh
Brolin's shoulders though I did for a
few takes and did you know he's a strong
man
he's been straining he's been training
or not and I've done it with him I've
done it with a stunt double I've done it
with a fake person you know like all
these it's all fun honest and um people
still people showed us all right well
we're gonna go find somebody I am living
for Quay always she is such a badass but
I need to go there's that moment that
she gives the sting kites
to halt or his banner in the in the
Hulkbuster how does she feel about these
Avengers doesn't know them well you know
listen her job and her mission and her
passion is to protect your conduct and
it's also now as an extension of Howell
Condon has incorporated something to the
world yes to protect the world because
we are the most equipped to do it so she
definitely is a part of that mission but
for some new compadres you know she's up
getting used to them
your people their motley crew
you know this guy's a little big and the
little
clumsy clumsy done beside I was epic can
he get it together can we use it you
guys the original Avengers have your own
language at this point where you know
the a 6-man the original six got tattoos
together by the artist the tattoo artist
who designed it and then we tattooed him
you tattooed the tattoo artist which is
he looked like you know maybe my
daughter did it you know I'm not sure we
did such a good job on him but it was
just embolism of our friendships and the
love that we have for each other and
it's the best takeaway of the last
decade of our lives is the friendship
that I have with the Krishna scar and it
already ended down in everybody so it's
that that's the greatest takeaway no I'm
like a grandpa grandpa with all its
grandchildren here meant to be together
fresh line maybe the end of us it's fun
we're having a ball you came here he
throws a boat show I know I was in this
world of the new Chris Craft is being
debuted this is exactly who I should be
up here with the man who literally
started all who had the faith in me and
this connection we had and and now at
this point he's the one moderating the
press conferences because he's moved on
he's moved on even more gigantic stuff I
don't even know what to say about this
did he had to convince you to play
Ironman quite the reverse we had
we knew we have to get miss everybody
else everybody else but by the way
that's you know it's all ya history is
interesting like we could rewrite it in
success but the truth be told is we were
hungry and we had a good feeling and so
seeing something like this tonight you
realize you're just part of something
and yet you kind of get to pretend
you're at the beginning of it but
tonight really feels like I don't know
it's special any given moment I feel
like I'm about to let some secret just
fly out of my mouth and I just want the
movie to come out that I have to I don't
have to hold anything in anymore yes I
can't do it and you must be exhausted
you've been around the world and back I
well I did go to London for a couple of
days and it was really really let's
quick whirlwind trip and the fans were
like so excited and so super I was crazy
over there and now we're back here and
yeah how about you I mean you must have
been traveling a little bit with this
film I mean maybe not as much as the
last infinity war tell us about it like
what's it like just how what do you do
to sort of when you get to a place you
need to sort of take a load off what do
you do to kind of revive your spirit
when you get there you go to the gym
right away or what well I'm so glad you
asked thank you so much Scarlett this
press tour has been actually not
exhausting for me because I haven't had
to do any of it given the circumstances
of infinite I must be great for you it
was great I sigh I did follow all of
your insta Live stories from Shanghai
and I wasn't there
Brazil Mexico City Ukraine didn't go to
any of those places you know I'm just
naming places but I was golfing and and
fishing the whole time which is great it
sounds very relaxing and really
productive how is war machine is he
getting up on his feet yeah war machine
continues to win the day he's gonna be
bad we're not worried about him he's
good and he's gonna be a fully
contributing partner in this book
most about endgame we've gotten tonight
that's about all I know Steve Rogers is
always gonna be Steve Rogers he's gonna
do no matter what anybody tells him even
when he was a kid you know he used to
just not listen and go and defend
himself the world he's got a big heart
so I'd probably just say follow your
heart buddy you're gonna be all right
there are so many great references to
the 90s and 80s think Captain Marvel had
you been any Blockbuster video store B
story before that moment yes it's like
my earliest memories are blockbuster
videos it's like the first time I
understood what indecision and anxiety
felt like we're at Blockbuster we've all
been able to enjoy our favorite stories
throughout our lives and we we think of
this movie as the ending of the story
that's been told for the past ten years
over these past 22 movies now and you
know this is the ending and like like
all of our hopes you know you always
hope that the ending is the best part of
the story and so I hope people are
coming into the movie with those kinds
of hopes and expectations and I hope
that we can deliver on that you couldn't
hold it together why be bad well I think
star-lord has you know his super power
is that he's part human and he's you
know got real emotions and I understand
that people are saying they're bad I am
too as a but also as a fan I'm kind of
happy because you know if it weren't for
star-lord you wouldn't even get endgame
you know I'm saying like you would have
a movie that was finished in 45 minutes
to give us a little bit of behind the
scenes of what it's like being on set
with the Russo brothers we know you
think you've or any secret it's like
it's like being given every key to every
Kingdom to make a film like this and you
have these incredible ideas and scripts
and characters and that's like let's
just throw it all away and play so
you're given all this responsibility and
then it's about
in the moment constantly keeping it
fresh and innovative a different and you
know one upping it and passing it as you
guys say and that's fun it's always
alive and with someone like Robert unser
who is the ultimate leading man you you
you have a good time the crew have a
shorter to hate you're working faster
and harder and it's fun and it's cool as
well which is a big cloak and a costume
I appreciate the temperature on a on a
Robert Downey jr. stage it's a it's a
good thing I just want to be clear no
trees were harmed in the making
during the making of this jacket my
friend Sonya biology and me that my
boyfriend actually had this made for me
because he's having fight the most geeky
romantic that's my sinuses I need to
know who here has an Avengers tattoo I
got my vise on my back and he got its
face son on my back scratch scratch and
sniff once so I smell like Buffalo he
smells like me and I just got myself
tattooed on myself so I can look at
myself
good luck with your test when you first
appeared in the MCU
it was a huge secret I mean we didn't
even interview on the carpet right
because it was such a big secret right
so what's it been like moving from that
and then seeing the public reception of
your character it's a great people yeah
hey guys as far as the sun's go you've
gotten to do some pretty cool stuff is
there one that was your favorite and
your I love every time they put me on
the wires to fly or to get whipped by
get hit by something I love being on a
ratchet I love being in a harness and
flying around it's my I mean it's so fun
and exhilarating I don't like roller
coaster
and this is my controlled adrenaline
rush we're talking about avenging the
Fallen are you gonna avenge Falcon or is
there someone else you're really looking
to avenge is here like what if the job
is done the job was done run who else is
there there's nothing worse than the day
of work you're unemployed your character
ant-man is so interesting because in a
lot of ways he provides comic relief but
he's also has been paramount to the
overall story moving forward I'm
assuming that's more of the same no I
haven't seen this thing I just hope I
made the cut yeah well I've seen you in
the trailer so I feel like your odds are
pretty good animated we've got a saying
it's Earth Day The Hulk is green is it
kind of like the Hulk's day I guess
that's what it is it's happy Earth Day
everybody it's a big one this could not
be more meant to be just smokes the gang
is all here together
welcome no you guys you and we have a
bunch of survivors here you've all
survived the snap an equal feet and a
selfie to remember it all
I'm just curious what was it like at the
moment that you found out that some
people were going away from you and some
of them right in front of your face oh
no because of this guy holy that would
be kind of Awesome tonight is tonight is
chaos just understand that it's quite
all right I enjoyed chaos Oh No so how
is it I mean what happens at the end
I'm just tell us about oh my god you're
not gonna believe it Gwyneth is actually
in charge of explaining of course she is
oh boy you know what I thank you so much
you know I think we should go ahead and
we're gonna keep partying down here on
our end of the carpet and we're gonna
toss back over to
the and Lorraine alz and Lorraine
[Music]